it's time for one of the biggest battles
our solar system has ever seen
in this corner a gas giant and
heavyweight Jupiter
and in this corner an infinitely small
but truly terrifying black hole
what would happen to these Rivals as
they hurtled toward each other
why would this event cause earth to be
bombarded by asteroids
and would it be game over for our solar
system
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter collided with a black
hole
okay before the fight let's take a quick
look at exactly what each Contender is
up against
starting with our Solar System's
favorite
Jupiter is the fifth planet from the Sun
located about 740 million kilometers
from it this gas giant is the largest
planet too
it's about
318 times more massive than Earth and
twice as massive as all the other
planets in our neighborhood combined but
looks can be deceiving compared to its
opponent the heavyweight Jupiter isn't
all that heavy
Stellar black holes are a lot smaller
than our gas giant but they sure can
pack a punch
the thing about black holes is that they
are dense
incredibly dense
all of their matter is contained within
an infinitely small Point known as a
singularity
and inside this tiny region
all concepts of time and space fall
apart
and like any object with mass black
holes have gravity a lot of gravity most
black holes are remnants of massive
stars
they're called Stellar black holes and
they range from 3 to 10 solar masses
but because they're so dense if a black
hole with 10 times the mass of our sun
appeared in our solar system
it would only be 60 kilometers across
so would our gas giant Jupiter stand a
chance to defeat its Tiny But immensely
powerful contender
or would it just be another object lost
inside the black holes point of no
return
everything in the universe is moving
through space at Breakneck speed and
naturally that includes the sun and the
rest of our solar system
we're whizzing across the cosmos at
about 720
000 kilometers an hour
and in this Galactic dance another star
may come close enough to us to influence
the outer regions of our solar system
or Worse we might run into one of the
nearly 1 billion black holes rampaging
around the Milky Way galaxy
yeah of course the chances of this
happening are slim the closest star in
our neighborhood is over four light
years away and that's far
scientists think that there's only a one
percent chance that another star will
ever come close enough to disrupt the
edges of our solar system
the chances of a rogue star coming close
enough to mess with Jupiter are even
lower
but it could happen
at first as this stealthy force of
Destruction swung toward us the black
hole would disrupt the Oort cloud
this area surrounds our solar system
like a giant spherical shell and it's
filled with icy objects
but these mountain-sized ice cubes would
be no match for a black hole
as they were pulled along for the ride
with this small but massive monstrosity
this would be the first sign that an
epic collision with Jupiter was
unavoidable
the gravitational Intruder would
continue through the next region the
Kuiper belt and it would wreak havoc
along the way
many of the icy objects here including
the dwarf planet Pluto would be ejected
from their orbits
things would suddenly get more serious
for Earth as many of these objects would
now be on a deadly Collision Course with
us
as it passed Neptune Uranus and Saturn
the black hole would tear away their
gases
these gases would form an accretion disk
of superheated gas and dust around the
gravitational intruder
and if the black hole came too close to
any of these planets they could also be
at risk of being ejected from their
orbits
then the black hole would finally Bear
Down on Jupiter and right away the gas
giant would experience a similar attack
on its atmosphere
the black hole would pull away hydrogen
and helium gases like yarn from a yarn
ball
eventually the entire planet would be
pulled toward the black hole
it would be an unfair fight from the
get-go
Jupiter wouldn't even be able to get a
punch in and if all this isn't violent
enough just wait
as this dense and hungry monster chowed
down on Jupiter's abundance of gas it
would also release an explosive wave of
UV and x-rays in all directions
yeah it would be like one big
supermassive burp packed with deadly
radiation
this radiation would hurdle toward us on
Earth
in less than an hour lethal amounts of
radioactive material would rain down on
us
but on the bright side you'd finally be
able to see the black hole up in the sky
whatever stability we enjoy in our solar
system would be gone
the black hole would be swallowing up
everything in sight including our planet
now if we somehow managed to be spared
the full brunt of the black holes
destructive forces well without Jupiter
our solar system would need to find a
new gravitational balance
yeah Jupiter had a special place in our
neighborhood
its enormous gravity kept asteroids and
comets from pummeling us and other inner
planets of our neighborhood
it also helped Earth maintain its nearly
circular orbit around the sun
so even if we survived all the
gravitational Havoc from a rogue black
hole without Jupiter this little space
Rock we call home wouldn't last long
but hey let's not kid ourselves what are
the chances this black hole would devour
Jupiter and then just stop dead in its
tracks no it's coming for you too
you'd get a first-hand look at what
would happen if a black hole sucked you
into its Event Horizon
hopefully you can travel faster than the
speed of light
otherwise your Annihilation would be
horrifying
but that's a story
or another
what if